what does your favorite art have to do
to get a hug around
oh I'm so happy to see you well oh the
house just isn't the same without you I
feel you look I really appreciate you
calling me every other hour
well I miss you
we all do
how's your distance with that sure about
that I know he would love to talk to you
yeah
look I'm just gonna be here for Ash and
not the drama all right
if you remember will when he first came
to live with us I told you a real man
makes choices he has to live with great
so this is just another lecture about
the poor decisions that I've been making
no
no it's about me owning up to mine
thinking about why I can't apologize
even though apparently everyone wants me
to
just don't regret wanting to protect you
I wanted to keep Blue from hurting you
I mean to be honest I don't really know
who
so the fact that he turned out to be a
bum
doesn't surprise me
but my mom I'm Dave and you lied to me
my whole life
that's what I heard
you put your trust in me and I let you
die
for that I don't even overdue apology
well
I'm sorry
thank you
I know we've been trying to find your
own way in South L.A
he hasn't got exactly how I planned it
well
I'm still here for you on your dreams so
if you're ready to come home
I promise that we could figure it all
out together
I love you will
I love you too
foreign
[Music]